34 shaheds, I am talking about the number and the name, and
it is quite specific that these are shaheds from the new
batch that Russia received from Iran, 250
pieces of stitches, all of them are now
received by the state, a terrorist, Russian
missiles and Iranian armor are used
constantly for strikes in front of everything on our
energy sector, and you have all the details about it  know
and ask you to increase the possibility of
supplying air defense systems to our country,
help speed up the relevant decisions of
partners,
one hundred percent air shield for
Ukraine, this will be one of the most successful
steps against Russian aggression, this step is
needed right now for our defense
operations to be successful. We need
modern, modern armored vehicles, above all,
there are no tanks  no explanation as to why
Ukraine has not yet received a decision to
provide modern and effective tanks,
in particular leopards, this is vitally necessary
today, on the day of the world Nicholas according to the
Eastern rite, Russian terrorists
gave Ukrainian children new blows,
I am asking you to support our country
right now  provide a clear decision about
what can not only preserve the current
dynamics on the battlefield in Ukraine, but also
accelerate the movement of our defense forces to
victory, because it will be our victory and the
victory of each of you did not just
happen Ukrainian children in their letters
to St. Nicholas ask for
air defense  they are asking for weapons, they are asking for a victory, a
victory for them, a victory for all
Ukrainians. They understand everything, our children,
let's act when
how long?
Who will find it? And we still have a
head. It seems that we can see this side. But
we can't see the road on that side. I went to
look in the room. There is no one there.